[Music]
I was just a child when I saw you there
you taught me how to fight sections that
just don't care through your lens
I saw beauty and hidden I kiddin half
[Music]
since I
where Tom's away in every shadow cast
and the evil eyes
[Music]
[Music]
did it show my hope it never fell to her
pirates Network win the war will fight
for freedom of system three and downside
such diverse
[Music]
I came
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hi guys
I see some of you have been trickling in
[Music]
17 hello 17 people have a little look at
the chat hey Dan
hey Raymond hey Debra she hey Newt not
cool hey Joker hey Albert hey Mark
how you doing hello I'm not gonna tell
you off the bat I'm actually really I
don't know I'm really nervous like I do
live [ __ ] was all the time but sometimes
it's just nerve-racking especially when
I'm showing you my game especially when
my game has changed a lot because
Facebook I mean it's really good to see
that Facebook are actually stepping
stepping up their mark I mean I can let
you know as someone who's been behind
the developer lines of Facebook that
they're definitely making massive
changes on how apps use people's data
it's just really annoying cuz I didn't
want to use people's say oh I just want
to see make a game yeah they're not
allowing approval of new apps I don't
know how long for but I've basically I
don't know I don't know how how clued up
you guys are on all the Facebook news
but it's the Cambridge analytics stuff
yeah hey Salvatore hey Mariana
hey Alex hey l4d hey Xavier hey caching
moment so we've all come in now hey did
you have a complete present evil 7 yes
yes yeah I probably saying that because
the videos seem to have stopped and it
didn't I did a charity livestream and we
raised two
150 pounds for Refugees yeah so I stayed
up all night and we did a little
livestream finishing that game enough
Resident Evil 7 it was very good it was
like the best horror game I played in a
very long time I think this is so cool
you're a game creator thank you I mean I
trying to you're gonna see but yeah I'm
just gonna tell you um I guess like
where ah this is also sorry again about
my voice I'm still I'm still I've had
this cold thing for like weeks now and
now it's just a sore throat and stuff
but um congrats dings I don't know
where's your toy star right so I don't
know if you guys have watched my
previous game dev streams or watched my
previous videos because I do have a
second channel called gaming with the
admin x-ray I put a few up there
throughout the development of this third
year game and basically it's actually
something I've been wanting to do for
years using people's social social media
accounts and integrating them into a
interactive experience because it's
really interesting not only does it
immerse you and it you brings in
relevant things about your life like
your interests or your friends or your
picture or you know something like that
also it's just a really good and
interesting way of making people realize
how easy it is for developers and things
like that to get hold of this
information so even though it's um it's
for entertainment I think it could also
be used for like informative purposes
because you could perhaps make an
experience where you have say like polls
in a bunch of stuff so anything from
your gender your religion your friends
names but then it digs deeper and tries
to get more information from you but
obviously depending on if you've got
your privacy settings on or not
depends on how much data can be pulled
so then you would have like
default things so if it couldn't pull
out that then you could have something
default and then that just shows you
know how public or private you are
online and you probably don't even
realize how public or private you are
online because we just don't really
think of these things anyway so that's
like that's an idea that I've been
wanting to play around for ages and I
really wanted to just try and tap into
that for my third-year game but
unfortunately all this Facebook stuff
has happened so it like immediately
threw me off track but I'm kind of I'm
happy in a way because I had all this um
code done where I showed you in the
previous video where it got your profile
picture your name your gender your
friends name and data and everything
else um and then it just stopped working
and I was like is this problems with my
internet connection or is my code
it's my code just suddenly not working I
did I put something in to like me crash
did I accidentally update unity did I
get the wrong like has Facebook SDK
upgrade didn't I need to upgrade that I
literally tried everything and then I
tweeted out just like I hate working
with the Facebook SDK and someone was
like yak man they have completely
changed because of all the analytical
things and I was like oh damn I looked
into it turns out that the data I was
trying to pull just comes back as null
now because it is protecting you so I
can tell you from experience you are now
being protected well I mean from new
apps anyway another going through
they're all apps yeah I can I literally
can't get most of the data that I was
using and it's just a relevant now
there's literally no point unless I just
want to get people's names and that's
just stupid I can just make them input
that so I've had to do major major
brainstorming around how to turn this
game around because well I have I have a
month well know I have three weeks until
my major deadline but I have an extra
month on top of that for my grad show
and then obviously I can keep on working
on it for you guys so
kind of don't know whether to release it
to you like I don't know whether to wait
until Facebook have started to
understand what they're doing and how
open they want to be with our SDK and
then see if I can implement that later
or just do this because I know a lot
like some of you don't even use Facebook
so you were happy that I wasn't going to
be used in the Facebook SDK and also
this means that I don't have to look
into hosting it and I don't have to
worry about restrictions on sizes for it
to be hosted online so there are like
packs - this is my rant yeah
Facebook always wasn't safe people just
now realize it well the thing is I don't
think like it's necessarily unsafe it's
just that you need to be aware of these
things it's not just Facebook it's it's
everything everything on the internet is
using your data it's just the way that
it is it's the way that the Internet is
you can't you know people thought that
you had the space that was free of
physical billboards and advertising no
now it's just all digital ways it's just
the way that our society is so well like
I said my original idea was to try and
open people's eyes using entertainment
as a platform but you owe to open
people's eyes about that in like an
entertaining less threatening kind of
manner and also I just think I just
think it's really cool because games are
the first interactive piece of
entertainment where you can do these
kinds of things if this is supposed to
run on a phone you could possibly no no
it wasn't gonna be on a phone it was
going to be just hosted online to play
either through Facebook game room or
just on a server you know online
Facebook did have their own thing second
Channel yeah my second channel is gaming
with Yacktman X there should be if you
go to my main channel I was like it'll
be on the side on the sidebar yeah
exactly
l4d it's yeah it's good that Facebook
could set up
they've really really set of protection
and I was looking into it and I was
trying to get what I had up on there
just to see if it worked but they were
like no we're not reviewing new apps at
this time I was like yeah okay fair
enough but I don't think that this will
be sorted by the time of my deadline so
but you know these things happen and you
either break down think I can't do this
and run away or you see is a challenge
and you're like okay what are the
because there's always good and bad
things that come out of any change so
you're to focus on the good things and
like I say the good thing is I don't
have to worry about Facebook sta don't
have to worry about it being hosted
online don't have to worry about sizes
or anything so I was gonna use Facebook
web hosting which has a limit to how
large the application could be so I
don't have to worry about that anymore
yeah mucho slow faster all the Uglies
are there that's cute joke oh oh you're
going already
okay I will see you later
so anyway don't even know where to start
I so instead of pulling peoples data
from online I'm just gonna be asking
them questions which but also I do have
some other things don't watch this if
you want to play the game without really
knowing the game I mean that's quite
obvious right and no obviously I'm not
making like a triple-a game or whatever
this is going to be you know it's an
experiment for me and but yeah we'll see
um I guess I should just kind of show
you water god I can't find it by
searching okay one sec one sec I mean
let me find my second channel for you
and I'll put it in the chat
[Music]
it is do here's my second channel to put
it in the chat for ya there you go okay
there's that
that's that oh you're very welcome
I'm really nervous a game just gonna
show you there's still so much to be
done I'm seeing so I'm seeing my
teammates too wait what is it Saturday
so seeing them on Monday it's been
Easter break I'm waiting to get like the
final environment and all the elements
and stuff before I properly setup the
way it looks but I'm still trying to
just finish the code at the moment and
everyday I just give myself a little
list of like what I hope to get done
today so today I've still got some
things to do before bed choose image no
no no I did I'm gonna change some text
disappear figure sort out the light to
again
I was going to talk to you about this
actually so everything every kind of
interaction you kind of have an idea in
your head I usually make up store bought
but then as you're kind of coding it you
realize little things that you hadn't
noticed before so you've got to think
about player and player movement and
kind of what they're gonna be doing
because you might I'm doing like a
walkthrough game which obviously has a
lot of events and triggers but then you
don't ever know how the player is going
to react to these triggers see you can't
just anticipate that they're gonna go
certain places do certain things you
have to think about everything which
it's all like I see it as I'm one big
puzzle
one big puzzle so let's just kind of
show you I guess I've been playing
around with kind of the way that it
looks I really I want to change a lot of
how it looks but I'm just gonna wait
until I get all the final assets and
things and then I know because I know
lighting is gonna change once more the
furniture and everything gets put in
here so there's no point me wasting time
now so okay but this is more or less
these are the textures that we're gonna
use at the beginning of the game they
all kind of change later on but we'll
talk more about that we need some more
lights here I think that figure out one
thing here I'm making a video and this
video is gonna be like a advertisement
for the perfection head sex that's what
this game is all about it's all about
becoming perfect putting on a headset
and then the world go stop to Derby but
it's mostly very kind of Bioshock vibes
black mirror as well using technology to
better yourself the Opera is very
old-fashioned actually I probably show
you a little piece of audio to go with
that so one second there is been working
with my producer on the music liaison
with people so I wrote a script for the
advert and it's gonna be playing on the
TV on loop and I will once this effort
is done I'm filming it tomorrow so I
will put it up on my youtube channel you
guys will see it very excited and it
won't be up tomorrow I'm filming it
tomorrow but I will put it up eventually
when it's like edited together and stuff
in there my friend is gonna help me with
the animation for it we're gonna put
some like animated text and stuff so
should I call it should look or think of
like um bye yeah kind of Bioshock /
fallout adverts and we have that like
old-fashioned yeah let me show you the
show genuine he is that he is a genius
though he's got a studio in West by
Brighton and called horizon productions
plug plug plug it's really really good
this ear ear it is this is the do you
find yourself dreaming of something
better than the life you lead where your
flaws can finally be yours to control
no more blotchy skin no more bad
headaches no more fear of failure to
achieve your goals here at never better
we believe in a perfect world and this
world starts with you we're committed to
perfecting perfect to make your wildest
dreams turn into a reality so you can
finally realize your true potential
[Music]
so what are you waiting for make
perfection yours make my back to you so
yeah I wrote that script I gave it to
Jamie and turned it into that and it's
frickin awesome I'm so proud of it
and then we use that and I sat down with
the girls gonna help me film the advert
and yeah we did a script storyboard for
it yesterday we're filming it tomorrow
so anyway that is going to be here wait
Wow I pressed play didn't I
dirt that's gonna be on this TV just
like playing on a loop so and this
woman's gonna be a lot lighter I just
don't know where my environment artist
wants to place all the lamps and stuff
so that's what we're gonna do on Monday
we kind of like trying to play around
with how I see the outside so playing
around with different sky boxes I've
realized I don't mind the sky box
hmm oh my god different sky box
I'm so picky yeah I've been trying to
like play around the trees are too small
grass too freakin large so I need to do
the terrain again but I know roughly how
to on it and one like a little pond
scene it's just first it's supposed to
feel like a building in the woods come
like in a rural part and I'm so I'm so
proud of these fireflies I made them
ages ago but they've got little light
trails and they look like they're flying
it's really cute because the beginning
of the game is supposed to put you at
ease and make you feel okay
but anyway so don't mind the way that it
looks
I was playing around with the logo it's
upside down but yeah I'm gonna have this
logo it's gonna be the right way around
and not overlapping the edges because
that is the never better is the company
name and that's the company logo and
this is gonna be like a kiosk screen
where you like
so please enter your name to login seen
this like Timmy for areas for ages
forever as well so that's like I need to
make sure they don't know head to a name
so if you press something against orange
squares for red
okay just a red layer and then you can
put in your name what should I name be
youngsters oh yeah
and yep submit and please choose your
gender supposed to say gender so we do
have an other oh yeah actually this is
what was gonna ask you as well so I
wanted people to choose their gender
when I was using the Facebook yesterday
obviously I was getting into their
Facebook but now I'm just like I've got
buttons also need to review the UI I
know it's early and then I'll so do my
friends is like basically I've got I've
got different models so if you choose a
male then you you become a male person
when you look down and there's the Khmer
on body if you're a female you look down
and you're female obviously and then
other that's like what-what can I use I
mean obviously I could use a generic
model where you can't really tell if
it's a male or a female my friend was
like oh you could do something cool it
you could do like an alien or something
like weird colored skin but then I don't
want to offend anyone so I don't want
anyone to feel like because they said
other that they're an alien so let me
know what you guys think about that so
I'm gonna say female because I'm a
female yeah I need to make that change
color and then okay
yeah so this was another thing I want to
do I was basically conveying until dawn
well watch my friend play until dawn the
other day
and I remember that therapy bit you know
where hey Alex hey ship on shopping
sorry that the yeah you know where the
therapists like he talks to you and then
throughout the game he gives you
pictures and he's like which one makes
you feel most uneasy I wanted to do that
here so these three pictures gonna
depict something I've got my friends
doing these three little illustrations
and one of them is a cracked and broken
like ugly mirror one of them is a bunch
of eyes looking new and another one is
like a spotlight and a silhouette of a
person with their back turn to you it's
basically supposed to depicts appearance
like I've been us and whatever being
judged with the eyes and being alone so
I'm just hoping to get which most
represents your imperfections yeah so I
just I'm hoping to get an insight into
the player and what they kind of feel
most uneasy about in their life so yeah
being around being judged or being ugly
either on the inside of the outside so
right now they're just little colors and
then that's the ends it's like we hope
you enjoy the rest of your journey to
perfection yeah brilliant
thank you so I look down like I've got
this girl body now just still needs to
be textured and stuff so my character
model is doing that I missile meets this
where you have like a little light I
want to make it cooler but like I could
use this how firefighters get out of the
house um yeah I kind of like this little
light like and everyone everything's
dark and believe me they can find an
that just lights up but only when you're
looking at it you can drop again drop so
yeah also so I keep saying um basically
in the hallway they there's gonna be a
bunch of advertisements lining the walls
so along here and it's gonna be a lot
brighter as well so the very beginning
but these are just placeholders at the
moment I'm waiting for my lights me my
environment artist and then I can
probably put the lights in this bloody
piece of grass just keeps coming to the
wall if it is crazy
and they're gonna come back again come
back there you are yes so they're gonna
align the balls and it's gonna be
pictures and these pictures are actually
based on the choice that you made at the
beginning of the game
so if it's about parents it'll be like a
close-up of face and smiling and eyes
and just like hands and stuff like that
if it's if you chose being judged it's
going to be people people in the photo
but not looking directly at the at the
lens I'm not looking directly you just
kind of like they're like do portraits
and stuff and then if chose being alone
it's gonna actually be the same ones
just people in portraits but later on
things change if when you have the heads
up on basically I want you to be able to
look at these photos and if you're
paying attention to them they change so
they start to like animate so I was like
how am I gonna make them animate and
change think of like Harry Potter right
so hmm why need to do is get a bunch of
pictures I've taken what would they be
called
you know when you take pictures best
best shots
of people moving so an eye closing or an
eye opening on people walking out the
frame taking best shots of that and then
put them in his textures so different
materials and then I've made this piece
of code where if you look at something
for over a certain amount of time so
I've put it on this pillow right now if
you look at something forever a
sentiment of time so there you go I've
looked at it for I think it was three
seconds or something starts to iterate
through the materials at the moments
just got generic ones on there and I've
got a speed so I can change that speed
and make it go faster or slower and then
when you look away it goes back to the
original texture so you can only see
that animation if you're looking at it
so you just got a this is this is how
well this is how I code anyway just do
everything kind of in the same room make
sure all the codes working and then I
can place it all around the environment
when I get all the assets that I need so
yeah that's that one bit of
functionality sorry I'm not looking at
chattels how do I get a pic of me in
there well actually that's what we're
supposed to be talking about today
because I wanna if you guys want to
include you guys in this game I mean if
that means that you would be wanting to
help me out with pictures and send me a
picture and I could like hide it in
there as an easter egg I mean I know a
lot people wouldn't want their picture
in there which I totally understand ah
twister corridor well I've actually done
a bag to go in fact I'll show you that
later so yeah I've got these two booms
and I was thinking as well for like one
of the rooms because you can peep into
them not this one though here peep into
the next one I can put the same
functionality on this one and maybe
after you wear the headset or even and
just make it got the whole thing I was
thinking of putting all the patreon
names I just say thank you stairs boys
cuz they help a lot oh yeah I'll just
put this like flashing thing so I know I
can do flashing lights and I can just
put that around
okay so here you probably like where oh
dude that's so light because I was
actually just working on one piece of
interaction functionality event event
and event trigger that so I want the
player to once a peek into this door
right I want them to be really intrigued
by it this was gonna be the door that
had your Facebook friends name on the
door where it says sample text there it
was actually supposed to say your
Facebook friends name hey why is this
material changed I changed that back a
while ago hold up wait a minute get to
see me change things they're just saying
I can't doo-doo-doo-doo doo-doo-doo-doo
so oh it's back to wallpaper food I
think we've change this to Commodore so
I've got this code on this where the
material switches after you put on the
headset no I've never tried Unreal
Engine we use unity in my university
what so creepy is someone actually
unfriended me for making one of them my
profile pic on Facebook wait what what
did you make his you're prepping my
friend took so many creepy ninety pics
of me in high school do you have an
example of a presence pic in the game no
I don't I've taken the pictures but I
haven't put them in the game yet cuz I
need to edit their I need to edit them
but I mean I was just using generic
textures there it will work I mean the
the code works I just need to put them
all in
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah do you help them here tonight okay
let's see if I can do this to show you
right now it's my friend likes - it is
56 to 60 in my unity oh did they stop
playing the item sorry
talk amongst yourselves BRB pictures
and paste isn't here okay no copying
over now mm-hmm ah thanks for asking for
people to thumb up the livestream
Raymond hey Steph are we
I think that's where the vamp is amazing
on money he plays with flock to pay to
have their face exactly that's what I
was doing sisters I was using Facebook
to put your face in but it's okay
hopefully after all this drama is
settled I can I can integrate that into
the game again so okay so that's okay
it's just says hold on it's important
the pictures that I just put in
so if I go to that hello how busy it
won't be on a pillow I don't know how
they show up you know
[Music]
elements and let's go was according I
think was just images yeah here's my
friend
okay so 55 then can you see what I'm
doing and I think that overlays okay
sorry
wait no you can't see that dying okay
hold up one sec can you see that
that's too big
locations okay you see this yeah okay so
image 55 56 57 I need more how many was
putting in that counting but I'll just
I'll just make it 10 for now that's not
what six to zero is a number do don't
forget to zero okay yeah cuz it's on a
pillow obviously it's not really showing
up that Greg's gonna iterate through
them though oh yes she is changing let
me change the speed duration event
triggered nine generations of
my well would it being Ward's a nice one
of these let's look at the code to me my
stuff better
yeah she's moving she smiled you see
that she smiled hey looks so weird
oh yeah basically that's what it will be
right like I can even make it faster
animations on 0.5 mm it's like a like
0.2 but yeah she'll obviously be she'll
be in a pillow should be oh wow this is
some crazy smiling she'll be in a
picture frame
she's gonna hate me showing you that I
am yep I am five okay down down down
down that gift pillow though she smiled
upside down yes so this is okay hold on
to your questions
hold on write them down we'll have a
little we'll have a little question chat
in a bit hello Debra she chorus we all
missed you
right so okay yeah so this is my thing
the door was supposed to have your
Facebook friends name on it now I've
changed I did something like crazy 4en
scribbles on house let me change the
events of this whole game without
Facebook so um what I'm gonna do now is
have instead of your friend's name on
the door it's just gonna say do not
disturb because this is well this is
like a therapy office kind of like
doctor anyplace and yeah so it's just
it's just so do you know understand
whatever and my
producer herds and productions we went
there we recorded some audio of like
mumbling you know saying things like oh
I heard she I can't see so you can hear
muffled voices behind the door so you
know someone's bad says don't disturb
but it's totally up to the play on what
they do about that this is really
important because I'm kind of basically
judging you on what are you doing this
game so I don't want to make it too
obvious at the same time I really don't
want them just walk past the door I want
them to be intrigued by whatever is
happening so my initial thought was to
go kind of Bioshock II and have a
trigger where when you walk to say here
all these main lights turn off
it all goes really dark and then there's
this spot like here on the door all the
lights are on at the moment I'm just
just playing around with them I seen let
you just put aside this live stream and
then if you high that's that's a default
guy in that because I thought it was
cool because um
the lights going off if I turn off the
lights
where's the lights lights lights lights
lights lights lights lighting I think
it's like
with my turn off these way light light
and why why okay still not about your
money but I'll work on it
yes so I wanted them to be like
intrigued and you can kind of see a
light coming through the door and you
see this light being stifled by I figure
I want the figure to go away but anyway
you can look on the door oh man she's in
the way
I haven't messed around with this UI at
all hmm I'm just ill sir I'm not sure
what I want from it
don't worry about the text at all this
is just kind of like copied and pasted
something else but I basically wanted
you to look at the door look at the door
and then it's it's got like a close-up
here of do you not disturb but then also
you've got two options so I'll make I'll
change these so that they look nicer
don't know what the new wine should be
look like yeah to either peep or leave
so you don't have to but you can peep in
and then if you look I have all mine's
me at the shiny that's good that was
actually one of our inspirations for the
environment so that's pretty good thank
you for saying that
um see you can peep if you want to at
the moment I'm seeing I put that light
in there - it's like majorly bright but
my idea for if you Pete was that the
room was actually empty and you're like
what and then there's like this John
scare this eye pops up up nowhere
someone's looking back at evening
through the peephole and like I jump
like Generic jump scare
and then you come back out and then the
light should be put back on by turn them
off now and then you can leave and carry
on walking but it's never that simple
right because you don't know what the
play is going to do you don't know if
they are actually going to pee or not or
just walk past the door and not even
care so I think we're gonna have to put
a Collider here to turn off all the
lights and make this one a bit more from
prominent and then oh maybe I'll change
the color of the light behind the doors
like a red or something that could be a
bit more intriguing and yeah so I
triggered to turn on the lights he
didn't turn off the light side here and
then if you decide to peep I will put a
piece of code when you not beat wait
this is how I wait I always have like
paper and then you've got to figure out
the logic first and then figure out the
syntax from the logic so you walk
there's one box Collider
one box Collider in the hallway say
about here I've made it when you walk
under the line because that would make
sense we're doing like why is it right
here so the lights just burst like it's
broken so okay so box Collider and light
light faults
so I need a sound to play as well mm-hmm
and then that's when so when the light
goes off so what I want is I want all
the lights to go off
let's go off so I know what I can do and
unity is I can just find find everything
of the component component of light so
I'll just find all the lights all lights
and turn them off and then I will
probably tag why I've already got them
in their own game object so I could just
try and but after I've turned them off
specify the game objects absence an
empty one just can't like door light or
whatever it is and then turn that back
on and I can also make that a boolean so
if that spot light is on then all the
other lights should be off so when we
then turn and we can make it like if
that one is off then all the other ones
should be on and that's the one I keep
no I don't think I would keep it on with
the lights on so I can make a boolean I
think like and then find
well yeah
where are you be there so I put it in an
empty game object I could tag it which
would make it easier to find in when I'm
coding so it could be like find game
object with tag and then I could put
this here like I've called it like
triggered also I could even give it a
tag of night record or see this is the
thing this is actually why I like coding
because it's literally like putting the
puzzle pieces together to try and get
the outcome that you want hello wait so
I I'm getting ahead of myself I need to
think back to the logic zone box
Collider under light lights fault
there's a sound let's go off all the
lights spotlight goes on spotlight goes
on um also it's probably when I should
trigger the trigger the mumbles or
should I have removals already there
no I'm gonna trigger the mumbles Martin
would it be would it be creepier if you
could already kind of hear the mumbles
and then the likes goes off the lakes
goes off probably because you might be
like at an the corner and then you're
like what's that noise and then the
lights go off and you're like oh what is
that noise yeah for you men yeah how do
you ban before
thanks for helping me out with dis life
I went out this guy doesn't know how to
go what's cooler than after passage yeah
yeah that's what I'm thinking I'm just
going through the logic catchin moments
but you're on my drift you get me get
the spoon so I can spin your heart out
something heard testing oh my god yes
Albert I'm guessing that yes was - it
would be creepier if you could hear no
no no no no this isn't I'm not gonna put
blood in the walls yet but that could be
an idea for after the headset because
this supposed to be like clean nice
normal environment unsafe for the head
zone and then I'll talk to my
environment artists about maybe some
blood on the walls then I will talk to
her about that I'm amazing let me write
that down blood on walls thank you very
much oh my gosh my chair is the walk
back so yeah I'm not gonna trigger the
audio audio is already mumbling is
already there but maybe I could turn up
the volume
yeah trigger mumbling audio increase so
you're even more intrigued then you go
up to him then you compete so this is
where you get your multiple choice so
you have to click on the door you
already know that you can interact with
things by clicking this that's what you
do in this game so you can click on the
door
and you get a choice to peep or to leave
you don't have to peep
if you peep no I'm going too far let's
just keep it simple
this is lit you just about the lights oh
wait no but yeah but then okay so if you
peep then the animation plays animation
plays and then after the animation is
finished
the camera switches camera switches back
to the main plan and I will add in some
extra code that means that the spot
light goes off and the lights go on
so I wanna kinda confuse the player and
be like oh the lights back on now what
why but if the player doesn't peep and
they decide to just walk straight
through past the door then yes exactly
he was it again ba ba ba where are you
where'd you say where are you I know you
said it somewhere in the chat looking up
oh wait was that you caching moments you
put another box Collider after the door
[Music]
and then that would turn turn spotlight
Oh like 10 spotlight off and Oh other
lights on okay
I'm really sorry if isn't that
interesting but that would be my logic
and yeah I think that would work
another thing that I need to change do
you this is so I need to probably just
show you the rest of the game press
bunnies change the Boop play please
thank you
I need to change the something some text
to say do not disturb and then after you
peep so if you do peep I've got a script
that has peaked as boolean so I can make
that so if peeped is true then the
sample text can change and that will
change to I warned you creepy age and
Jamie has made this piece of audio it's
like what are you hoping to see so once
you're looking severe you get the audio
from behind you and it's like someone's
there but not really that's just playing
with you so yeah there's that then that
changes so anyway so I got my body
I've already peeped it's to deny you
already peeping hi so then you walk down
here it won't be this dark
on the headset what's gonna happen here
is you take the headset there's gonna be
an animation where it'll put terian yes
that would be I'm gonna put down it
indefinitely
there is a monster in this game but I'm
gonna put Terran just like Easter I was
thinking maybe just be standing in the
woods or in the second room but I kind
of like in the woods now like in the
distance and you only spot him if you're
nothing that would be cool yes I'm gonna
turn away Terra in the woods thanks for
that laureate and yeah so when you press
this yeah an animation of your eyes
blinking and then closing I got that
from my last game so I don't know if you
guys played Snoop Francis the Google
cardboard game but I've got a blinking
animation there but I might look and see
if I can find a nicer one as well so
yeah there we go and then we've got some
audio that Jamie and I are working on
where it's like using the planning to
have mechanical noises coming closer
into each year so you're better if
you're playing it with a headset and
then it's supposed to sound like you're
kind of putting mechanical objects into
your ear holes and then the drills
through and then you open up your eyes
again and this monstrosity is stuck
behind you
obviously wearing this now so that's
just it's like oh my god The Closer that
you get the more the cars like and scope
isn't breathing in there
we've got male and female breath I don't
know what's used for other this is
another thing I don't want to I don't
want to make anyone see you're like I
don't want to offend anyone so I don't
know whether to give them a female or
male breath or just maybe a bit of both
maybe
just randomize and it picks at random
but yeah so there's that the further
when you get from the monster you stop
panicking I'm done with this screw this
and then you're like oh wait he's gone
but where does he go
what do you wanna when it's really
tumped touching himself I think I might
say true
[Music]
oh yeah this is just to show that I can
change the material but you just go
through the wine so I've got this yeah
this is the whole way so my lecture
wanted me to go through the whole way
twice so he wanted to be like a gradual
thing because I was gonna change the
whole environment as you put the headset
on it becomes more horrifying so all the
materials I like really grow some stuff
so this is when I can put like blood on
the walls and things like that and they
can put assets in the front there before
and just make it like really horrible
because basically is supposed to be a
representation of imperfection
everywhere so you put on that head say
false and then in imperfections are
everywhere what's wrong with there
making monster you got something wrong
with nudity it's supposed to be an
ambiguous monster that kind of
personifies everyone's imperfections we
have videos on that actually over on my
second channel so the purpose is if you
peeps
into the room it peeps back at you this
is actually what's the word influence no
inspired by along the dark a new night
man and we've got some pervy breathing's
given there as well but I need to change
the camera a lot and make sure only
doesn't see that much so yeah you get
watched you get looked at because you
destroyed so this was the vascular
effect that I was playing around with so
if you know there's a monster again if
you know Alfred Hitchcock he's actually
do this thing where he extends corridors
and staff say the your subjects stays
looking the same
but everything else elongates around so
that's what I've done here it's just
thing about with it not just gonna use
this effects until the very end of the
game but I think it works really well
especially in conjunction with Oh balls
what the hell wow what just happened
two liters jumps everywhere why am I
here okay this is bugs bugs everywhere
this is pretty than that
okay that was what was supposed to
happen there's a Collider that I
obviously need to make a lot bigger that
sends you back here and then once you
hit that Collider I can make more things
happen so I can change this is what I
can actually change I don't know if I'm
making any sense the second time around
the materials switch oh yeah so the
first time around is when I'm gonna have
that all the photos the sprites
iterating through if you look at them
and then the second time that you go
through the hallway the photos have
changed to the end pictures in the end
picture I wanted to pitch like the
imperfection that you chose at the
beginning of the game so if you chose
alone all the pictures of the people
will let you just be empty frames they
have like left they have like
Shirley left you alone then not in the
picture anymore if you chose appearance
it's going to be flaws of people
people's parents so wrinkles bruises you
know all that kind of jazz if it's about
if you chose judging in the eyes okay I
got bugs to solve I'm sure it's just it
was working fine earlier so I'm sure
it's just a new script I put in that's
probably mm-hmm it's probably just
changed this functionality but yeah it's
basically it I'm working on it event by
event so the end is basically you go
back to the main bit here if it where
you come in and then the monster is
behind the glass and it doesn't prompt
you where to go but hopefully they'll
try and leave through the exit which is
the door here that you staffing and when
you click that door this door opens and
that's like the reception door that's
been locked throughout the whole game
and then you come here and then then the
reticle happens through this long
corridor the monsters at the end and
about I'm actually got a script that
times how long it takes you to reach the
monster and then at the very end well
then let's go off monsters gone but you
have like a booklet what are the chords
and what's the chords people keep files
on a file I guess yeah your your file
and it tells you how observant you've
been throughout the game tells you if
you know Z or not which is if you can't
do the room Oh
Facebook it tells you how brave you are
which depends
how long it took you to go towards the
monster at the end of game and also at
the beginning of the game once you press
see the monster if you go up to him
there's an animation of him hitting the
glass which we're using mocap for next
week next Friday to do that so if that
animation gets triggered you'll get a
bravery point so tell you how preview
are anything else I think those it's
just those three things that I'm kind of
judging you on and basically in the game
you can interact with items you don't
need to you so you can like pick stuff
up or you can like oh yeah I forgot that
well you can umm and every time you look
at something your observance egos up so
you can play this game a few different
ways and like oh no I wouldn't say it
has replayability but it's just supposed
to be kind of observing you and how you
are as a player or a person like whether
you run through the game or whether you
decide to spend a bit more time but like
I said I want to see if I can have you
guys kind of in here as little Easter
eggs so maybe even I was thinking
because this game is about perfection
and about fear of imperfections I mean I
won't wanna make you do anything you
don't want to do but if you wanted to
send me like no other name just a
sentence that represents your fears or
your imperfections then I can maybe put
little scripts of paper or I could like
and write them on
our notebooks and stuff throughout the
game and those can be the the pick up of
all stuff that people can view if they
want to it's nothing
they don't have to this game is more
experimental just to see how people
react to the game that makes sense
because you are being judged throughout
the game because I quite like how in
Sandhill too they had multiple endings
but you didn't even realize until one
even until you got to the end you still
don't really know because they were
judging you on how you played the game
without making it obvious and games
nowadays it's kind of like a fad you
know to have options and you know are
you gonna save this person will save
this person are you gonna are you gonna
do this week and I'm gonna be good
you're gonna be bad but there's not
really many games that that are judging
you or you know making perceptions of
you and your personality without you
realizing because in my miners the
that's a like a true a representation of
the player because it's not really
giving you options that's why I didn't
really want to give you the option of
people leave but I just can't really
think of any other way around it I mean
if you guys some things just let me know
oh yeah Alex it'll definitely sound
better once all the audio is added in
when you're pleased to follow I mean do
you think do you think it needs clues
it's quite linear in the environment so
I'm hoping it will be kind of obvious
where to go because the doors will all
be locked apart from the ones where you
need to go in and the thing with horror
games is you need to kind of just let
people explore the environment because
if you make it too obvious the unease
kind of goes away the monster is a judge
imperfections equals mirrors maybe
we did have this ending idea where once
you got your ending and you got the
booklet telling you about stuff you look
down at yourself and you're the monster
and when I could change that to there's
a mirror at the end so you can see
yourself as the monster I'll write that
down mirror and question mark see
yourself mr. perfection is your
unprofessional mm-hmm descent into
madness I think how does that game Alex
it sounds yeah it sounds like something
I've heard oh by the way am I really
quiet I don't know I put myself up you
just
uh-uh Ram you need I didn't actually
look at very many you knees to be honest
I have my heart set on this this course
called can no digital film screen arts
but it turns out it wasn't what I
thought it was so I changed I changed my
University and I think I can stay for
much longer guys some video did you
place oh man the start of the game how
does cinema star know I didn't I've
actually I think I've got so much I
wanna steam let me just so maybe I could
just play this dog so much and get some
inspiration for month
yeah Danny I was actually thinking of
doing that poor screen as well but
that's just too much for me to do
through my deadline but yeah I love how
Petey did that which is exactly why I
wanted to do the camera thing where
they're looking at you because then you
know the control gets taken away from
the player and hopefully I'll just freak
them out a little bit because they won't
see it coming neverending story does
this mean to the soundtrack to that the
other day many movies always toy with
the idea that if one tree sees
themselves as who they really are inside
people when are we screaming like the
mirror in high pots of what you mean the
mirror of Erised said or we're never a
nice toy oh that's nice mom oh we're
never any story when Sebastian saw
Atreyu in the mirror oh I like this idea
okay I'll write this down
Mira I quite like ya your mirror the end
is at the NCO surface monster you are in
perfect perfect perfect is the you we
help shameful um yeah well I've never
played an amnesia here of time but I've
I've watched it all and I know do you
have to know a bit about gaming and how
they made to get into uni not at all I
mean I was in a pretty good position
where I was um I was actually a
front-end web developer and like
advertising before I went to uni so I
was just like I just went to uni and
then I just wanted to change my course
and then they were like what do you know
and I was like a play log games love
games I know like how to code websites
so it's gonna be kind of similar and
then they were like yeah sure
you can come no I was like cool so that
was my experience
I think as long as you're passionate and
you do play around with it because I'd
had made a game before coming to uni I
did like a unit in my media diploma so
if you play around I mean unity unreal
it's all free so as long as you can show
that you're dedicated and you're
passionate it should be good mmm I
remember in our horror game that we had
a bug that the sound of bottles the
player would knock over was too hard and
somehow I got the gasp sound file at the
player we forced the plates move towards
the space of the bosses put a knock over
but it somehow tied together so
apparently they lived in it's not a bug
it's a feature hey sorry it's not a bug
at the future hey mantas your true shame
guilt is your monster oh that's quite
cool yeah see if if I so would you guys
be like up for that do you think that's
a good idea
if I ask you guys kind of like right
either your your take on imperfection or
perfection as a quote or like if you
want to get personal or write about your
own obviously I'm seal name or anything
but you know like I don't know like I
think if people know the true me they
won't want to be around me on me I don't
know if you wanted to write so like that
then I could I put these quotes in the
game or would you rather it be a picture
or you know how how might I involve you
[Music]
like the perfection idea same as someone
believing they're compressing their
whole life and then the reveals oh
another concept of this it's such a cool
idea and a new way to make it personal
for the player thanks Danny
I'm glad I'm trying I'm trying my
hardest I'm pretty decisive don't go
away there's been so much time and
effort spent on this Facebook stuff and
like my lecturers have never used any
SDKs or anything before
we're not the Facebook one anyway so I
was literally like teaching myself ah
I'm just so annoyed because I did so
much work mmm oh well oh well I'll still
just try and make this as cool as I can
I just need to get the final environment
I need to make it look better cuz I keep
feeling really disheartened because this
doesn't really look how I want it to
look at the moment but I know I need to
be focusing on the main event like the
event triggers and interactions and
everything first and then I can focus on
the look and I know I'm gonna have I
mean the audio sounding great I'm gonna
have that video the pictures as well you
know I've been trying to do everything
just to try and get this together cuz
it's supposed to be Easter holidays so
I'm not actually in uni and I'm not
actually with my team or anything so I'm
kind of like my own with this like what
if perfection was the enemy well yeah I
mean I can't change the ending or
anything like basically it's supposed to
be perfection isn't real like it's it's
not attainable like you start this game
and it's all these wonderful pictures
and advertisements about how you're
about to become perfect and you know
whatever but actually once you put on
there the perfection headset
the whole world around you just gets
turned around it all it like amplifies
the imperfections that you see and your
faith because perfections is nothing
it's not real work you put don't go in
vain it make you throw I mean I think
you may make oh yeah oh crap
yeah exactly and I'll still have this
game afterwards and like I say hopefully
it's a Facebook SDK well become easy to
work with again after they've saw it all
this stuff out and then I hope like it
implements it again and I've got all
this stuff in now so I can just use the
best of both I can get people's Facebook
data information but also I could use
this stuff I just thought it was really
cool to use your profile picture it just
sucks
mmm Wow so yeah did you do it do you
like the idea of the text I don't think
anyone's did you see anything I'm just
looking to the chat
oh yeah I could do writing in but yeah I
could use the same the same code as I
did for the pictures oh good work are
you dropping the Facebook SDK a half t
Montes they're not allowing like they're
not reviewing new apps and a lot of the
data that I was pulling in it doesn't
get pulled in anymore because they they
have liked really restrictive
definitions which is good is a good
thing because of what happened it's cool
I deal with the text cool okay so what
I'll do them if the text is a yay would
you one like I can put it well yeah
it'll be up to you you could put leave
like your YouTube username or whatever
and I could like put that there as well
if you just wanted something to be like
hey so let's have looks like Facebook
oh they're Facebook thanks get out of my
head you know other thing anymore okay
alright YouTube subscribers into my game
add I asked for the fears around
imperfections or relevant quotes and
then put these
um inspect sapore items throughout the
game and I can actually put at the end
when I say like how observant they were
I could say how many of those that the
player had found because he probably I
won't make it obvious and then they were
like oh I didn't know there was things
that I could find so it could be like
sort of like collectibles maybe that'll
be a nice to have
then how many founds at the ends I could
be cool
I think the game will work fine without
the Facebook SDK your idea the Texan
mind me of a beginner's guide I think
this could make the game even more
massive text beginner's guide hmm I'll
have to check that out thank you very
much caching moments begin - the galaxy
is that thing
I'm going crazy literally the only thing
that has gotten me through this is a
know little ring soundtrack so we wanted
to watch all of the wings I tried to
watch all of the rings I got wait and
extract it was like okay now soundtrack
is and Disney songs Easter eggs how
fitting exactly we're adding the Easter
eggs mantas with think in the
collectibles so you guys can do your
thing I'm gonna put some patreon names
not some or the patreon names in the
second room in the second room and make
that people keep a bowl and put terror
because I've got Tara's model in the
woods after you put on the headset of
course
may it be Anya what sounds like the
player messages in Dark Souls games oh
yeah I love our Dark Souls do that do
that does that it's cool it's very
useful as well in that came if making
new club paying for you are used to play
actually let's do this now
might as well I used to play hotels any
remember that I used to spend all my
pocket money getting like a new dog or
something
they still of that pepper balsa asking
for the real oh you know canny two main
thing was amazing yeah so we got themes
I wonder if I should show you some audio
key down this game no this is like a
walkthrough game so it's uh yeah it's
more like experimental I know not
everyone likes that but the whole reason
why I don't know why I got into this was
just it was more about yeah experimental
but now you can't die the monster never
actually comes near you you have to go
near it but then it disappears
oh yeah through the hallway as well I
want to do like a bendy in the ink
machine thing where he's like peeping at
you around the corner
Olivia goes away again I know I've lost
so much stuff to do but it's okay cuz
just bit by bit every single day I will
get it done it will be okay and yeah I'm
just gonna go to manage my team as well
make sure that they're okay
and doing stuff get me all the things
and liaison with boards of peoples but
we got some really really cool music
like ah so when you're walking through
the hallway I'm gonna make the hallways
super bright at the beginning of the
game before you put on the headset and
we've got this cheesy like hallway music
[Music]
ah yes and the jump scares Pepe will be
first jump-scare if you choose do will
be when you keep in the doorway and
there will be nothing there and then
suddenly the eyeballs then it's like
watching you then the second jump-scare
will be wow when you put on the headset
and then you open your eyes and then
once is their third I guess is if you go
towards the monster then and then he
puts his hand on the on the window like
forth it's not really a jump-scare but
when you're being watched through the
door supposed to like just kind of freak
you out they'll bear and then yeah I
guess you don't you already have oh yeah
the when you're going through the
corridor on the second time you see the
monster like peering at you but then
it's gone so like a bending the jump up
bending in the jump-scare bending in the
ink regime jump-scare and then the end
of it will be more like a build up and
what would he be a jump-scare be a build
up the monsters the end just waiting for
you to come the vertical thing hopefully
he works I'll figure out why that's not
working and then once you reach it all
the lights will go off and then you'll
get your little your little book with
your results and maybe a mirror we'll
see we'll see if they can put that in
because that's a good idea like that I
like that ending mm-hmm yeah
yeah elevator music tonight it would you
say good gig again like stuck in a quiet
room and you forced to watch the view
for eternity that would be nice at first
and then horrible uh yeah there's a few
people at she doing horror games in the
course one guys doing kind of like an
amnesia style game where you go through
and then you polar switch and then an
enemy gets released and then you gotta
try and find your way out and then
another team are doing like an alien
bunker one where you've got a gun and
you like can shoot the aliens and get
out I think those are all the horror
games yeah
if you want to hear the the concepts of
this game rails can fly you can watch my
love you can check out my second channel
came in with yog max or you can watch my
latest video
I do explain roughly like what this game
is about and by hero go save the day oh
sorry does anyone have any questions
about like the game dev stuffs so I've
got some stuff to do before I go to bed
so like I said I make a list for myself
every day of what I've got to complete
and I don't know why but usually I'm the
most put up safe at night time if this
is the way that I work so right now I've
got to sort out the spotlight and we've
already sort of the logic for that so
we'll just get on with the cold and then
got a change a text on the door and oh
yeah make sure that the dude isn't in
the room when you look
[Music]
I use unity just because we have to in
uni that's all they teach in I do want
to try on buildings obviously if you
have more experience with different
stuffs then yeah you know better things
you need sleep okay I'm gonna go you
guys is what you need sleep I do I do
I know but thank you so much for
watching and thanks for helping me with
the ideas I like because I just want I
want to get you guys involved and it's
just it's come around so quickly and I'm
always the kind of person that gives
myself way more to do then is actually
possible so I don't know I mean just
because I'm out of uni doesn't mean I
won't still be making games and
hopefully I can carry on making them and
making my visions come to reality it's
just really difficult when you have like
a time limit and not many people I mean
I'm the only one that codes in my groups
so I'm like but it is really good to
talk through logic with people when
you're coding cuz they helped you kind
of like put the puzzle pieces together
in your head it's really nice even if
even if you're not talking to another
current you just talk to someone you say
okay I need this to happen so if they do
this and then go then and do this and I
know sometimes maybe it just doesn't
make any sense and they just seems like
going on a tangent but it really really
helps us to like talk it through yeah
oh oh wait wait wait I feel like I've
had as the beginners guide let me just
quickly check this out before I go the
same one from the same depth was also
good well I might have just seen it on
Steam and eventually you come to a
folder that just says mutt what would
you say you know about this person right
now
like maybe they're kind of goofy okay
you close that you scroll down a bit and
you open up a new file it's another game
do you think this person is happy are
they unhappy now another one what do you
think is comfortable for this person
what puts them at ease
do you think they're lowly what's
missing in their life
keep going open another file let's look
at all of them let's unpack this person
are they upset about something we're
fighting something what do you think
makes this person I'm just watching
trailers oh of course that's how I know
the game the Stan Lee's parent Stanley
Stanley parable yeah
I will definitely play that one and okay
if you guys want me to make it into a
video that I will I will do more gaming
videos after uni is over definite
because I've already do mystery them
it's just that they do take a long time
to do and yeah I'm real is free I'm
realest for unities free yeah anyway
yeah so thanks again umm what should I
do okay how she asked for you what I
will do is I will set up a folder in
Google Drive and I'll put like I'll put
a little document in there just saying
what I would like for the game maybe
like a maximum character counts and if
you want to you can have having little
something put into the game just your
own take on imperfections or maybe your
own imperfections that you feel you have
where you got your board you might have
or others might think you have and then
feel free to put your like your first
name there like don't think you should
put your first and then second name
there but I mean can do if you want to
or like your YouTube your YouTube
username
so I can obviously put that there and
then we can use that as a little
collectible I think that'd be really
cool cool Easter Egg for you guys I like
that idea so yeah I do I set up a Google
Drive and I'll share the link I will
share the link most likely through
Facebook and Twitter but Twitter is
always the best place to go to follow me
in my daily endeavors so I will just
give you a quick link to my Twitter
account so you have it and yeah I'll
definitely tweet out the link to that
Google Drive I'll put it in my discord
if any of your patrons I put it on
Facebook as well and there you can just
upload your files and yeah that'll be
cool so a hashtag on Twitter oh it could
be a hashtag on Twitter I don't think
I'm big enough for a hashtag there but
it could be a hashtag that could be
easier right then asking you to upload
something into a Google Drive maybe what
if I don't use Twitter there's all these
things if you don't you swear geez
Facebook I'll just ask ya I'll figure
out I use a hashtag and I'll do the
Google Drive idea so there we both I'll
be looking for the hashtag and I use
Google Drive and I'll put the Google
Drive link out on Facebook on Twitter
[Music]
is there anything else I can use Oh my
discord for my patreon mmm-hmm yeah
whatever this this should be enough and
my my Facebook is the same it's just
HTTP facebook.com slash yeah good man X
the only thing with Instagram is you
can't put links in Instagram to see
really annoying thing I mean and it's
not like a text-based thing you know
it's a picture based thing if you do
Google Drive so you can have a setting
where when you share in it let me just
double check this when you share it it
can be a view only and I think that the
view only or is it where I can view let
me change this can be you can edit can
comment yeah so that you can view only
upload though
I think with you only you can upload as
well but you just can't like edit
anything in the Google Drive Google is
my best friend Google knows everything
[Music]
people can open edit delete or move
files people couldn't see the folder but
can they upload in there he's not
telling me these things I don't know
I'll find out what oh my gosh
one of my course mates is just sent me a
horrendous snapshot from tonight this is
great thank you
anyway yeah I'll find out and then oh
let you guys know what is happening but
the hashtag is definitely wack as well
and then yeah we'll figure it out but
thank you so much for helping and
watching I know it probably doesn't seem
like much now but trust me there's so
much kind of like hidden code and stuff
I just need to put it all in and oh okay
and then after my deadline I'll just eat
all the ice cream sleep for days I'm
just happy you're camping yes I'm
already thinking about the deadline I'm
actually thinking of going to maybe go
into Iceland weather with Laura my
friend I'm really excited
anyway I'm just rambling now so hi robo
well if you stored all the user data for
your games somewhere and have the game
import that information in have the game
important importance of what they
important what input for one input to
one for what it's nice come tomorrow
that's just breaking the wall sketching
moments I gotta wait until my game is
finished that's just rude Fenrir now
you're paying on my imperfections have
you ever gone skydiving no I always
think about of them like what I go yeah
I probably would go
I'd be so freaking terrified but I would
do it yeah why not
you only live once Yolo no don't say
that
yeah I'm gonna go thank you again for
coming and all of your lovely comments
and everything I think I'll say thank
you a thousand times them the rules are
meant to be broken
not the rules you set yourself or maybe
I don't know I'm very strict with myself
very strict myself me to you but I would
do what about key to ice cream what is
key to ice cream do if I haven't had ice
cream in ages because of this you have
given up milk and eggs and everything
thanks for very but still you should not
say someone don't eat ice cream yogurt
fat because anyone is going to take that
it's kind of rude yeah blablabla
perfection is a great project
thanks Ruben I appreciate oh yeah I was
gonna figure out what the hell key to
ice cream is Akito
what is keto ice cream oh look it's got
like um 320 calories halo top sea salt
caramel there's only four pounds that's
not bad actually I thought it would be
like this crazy expensive ice cream
there honey rich people we tried doing a
submission project and he thought some
of those yes let me share with you a
link I have one for you too much already
she is called Tina the teabag actually
you're probably you're probably thinking
like something different but this is my
stop see my version of stop-motion
animation is it's drawing it's like yeah
wait let me specify stop-motion
Photoshop drawing video
okay so now I believe um what's the time
oh bloody ah yes 11 I've got stuff to do
before I go bed no I'm gonna go bet it's
gonna be good and I hope you sleep too
and oh I will update you let's say I
will update you next week next Friday
Oh a lot should have been done by then
so fingers crossed
wish me luck but I know I got this we
got this
I'll let you know do you follow me on
Twitter about being involved in the game
because it would be cool I would love to
see I would also just love to see what
you write we like super interesting to
see yeah I'll catch up with you soon
have a lovely day or evening and bye I
guess I'll say I'll say goodbye to you
because I always say good bye to
everyone that I can see so I will do
that now so good night Simon good night
Raymond good night lads can fly good
night Luke house good night from the
rear good night Newt mantas I saw it
good night pandas good night
[Music]
anyone else good night I'm trying to see
everyone that I haven't good night Bobo
if you're still there
good night Salvatore Mary feels good
night catching moments good night
Raymond I think I my voice said I keep
on saying Raymond as in like Rain Man
but ramen ramen good night mark good
night
shebang good night Cyrus
good night laureates good night go Lord
good night
Federico Mazzella and thank you good
night goodbye so I don't know I'm I
don't know I'm just a bit l my voice
isn't the best right now
why did you retract your message
Scarlett didn't you just say good bye
good night Simon yeah I'll sing for you
another time if you if you watch me on
Instagram if I ever get the urge to sing
I need you just go live on there so just
try and do that but um maybe next week
hopefully next week I feel I feel bit
better
I've just had over had a really really
stressful last couple of weeks to be
fair but I feel like I'm I feel like
it's getting on track now I feel like I
feel better I do for weather and it's
like oops yes we noticed collide yes we
noticed and goodnight oh no lights no
light that's an interesting name so yeah
have a lovely evening good night to
everyone who's watching that wasn't in
the chat so yeah cuz I know I knew you
liked us are there because I am one team
I see this every time that's where like
every time I - I Milaca I will leave
this up for a bit just if you guys want
to chat anything
chat you can just for a little bit so
yeah goodbye
you
we bro everything that was right we both
enjoyed a good fight and we so oh the
holes we had some food to make the other
one D and that allowed the way looks of
me
[Music]
the way made me feel we were alone
[Music]
just for you
[ __ ]
like is
[Music]
we stole every moment we had make the
other one from where and we hope we can
be what we mean we'd never turn out to
be real
[Music]
looks at me
[Music]
we may be feel
[Music]
we're alone
[Music]
just
[Music]
yes
[Music]
return back
[Music]
turn back time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
right
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
just
[Music]
okay
just
[Music]
like we
I can't wait forever not that patient
I've got too many things but it's your
comfy
I can sweat but when the Sun comes out I
won't be needing his smile conceals a
secret and it's a sickly sweet that I
can't see the point of taking Ziva
through the surface line is just so
beautiful I don't wanna spoil your soul
please don't leave this to go cold your
eyes make me feel dizzy when you quiz me
on my childhood history I'll share it
with you if you so kindly got me oh so I
can see I kept right through the cracks
so goodly glued the view straight on to
me that instead I enjoy this view the
dice of shallowly and feet I don't wanna
spoil my soul please don't leave this to
loco if the best things are worth
waiting for
but you disagree would you only see the
no but here's where we both are and I'm
too afraid Turner
around and see how far and see how far
because I can't wait forever I've got
too many things into your can't see like
a sweater when the Sun comes out I won't
be any day
[Music]
because I might but it's his arms and
heart I like me it's okay - I love Wendy
[Music]
it wasn't in fact you cut me but you
took me away from all I knew just bigger
[Music]
in my because we shout his feelings I
[Music]
it's his time
[Music]
I
thank you
smell time that you
I wish to share with you you were too
smart when you loved me away but I have
confession it was a choice today
[Music]
me
[Music]
my
[Music]
it's his time it's oh please
[Music]
wishing to become a real boy fill the
room the real touch and joy but I am
hoping no Kyojin Peter Pan's shadow
[Music]
you
you